I
because this consciousness at first
knows universality only as immediate and
necessity as necessity of the heart the
nature of the realization and the
activity is unknown to it it does not
know that this realization as what
affirmative Lee is is in truth rather
the implicit Universal in which the
individuality of consciousness which
entrusts itself to it in order to be
this particular immediate individuality
really parishes instead of acquiring a
being of its own if there for teens to
being the alienation of itself but that
in which it does not recognize itself is
no longer a dead necessity but a
necessity animated by the universal
individuality it took this divine and
human ordinance in which it found is an
accepted authority to be a dead
authority in which it found not only its
own self to which it clings as this
particular independent heart opposed to
the universal but also those subject to
that ordinance which would have no
consciousness of themselves but it finds
that this ordinance is really animated
by the consciousness of all that it is
the law of every heart it learns from
experience that the reality is a
vivified ordinance and it learns this in
fact precisely and realizing the law of
its own heart for this means nothing
else then that individuality becomes an
object to itself in the form of
universality in which however it does
not recognize itself
in paragraph 374 Hagel is now outlining
for us two different points of view one
of which the self conscious individual
motivated by the law of the heart trying
to enact it trying to actualize it is
able to take into account but which
turns out to be a mistaken view and the
other view which it's not able to see is
the reality which is this necessity
animated by Universal individuality as
he's going to call it a world in which
the ordering is not as oppressive and
alienating as it's made out to be by by
the person who can only see things
through the lens of this law of the
heart so he says because this conscious
consciousness it first knows
universality only as immediate so what
we're doing here is taking the view of
immediacy and remember back to several
paragraphs before this where Hagel talks
about the law of the heart as being a
viewpoint being a shape of consciousness
that is not yet undergone a kind of
disciplining back and forth with the
world but it just wants to get out there
and change the world so it mistakes the
world that it wants to change in the
process you might say it sets up its own
conflicts in a way so he goes on and he
says it knows universality only only as
immediate and necessity as necessity of
the heart so it places necessity on its
own side and that is what what spurs it
what gives it the energy to go out there
and start transforming the world right
through its agency its action its its
externalization of the law of the heart
and it tries to do something that is
going to be expressive of universality
we saw in the previous paragraph that
there are a few paradoxes that this
raises for example in universalizing its
own perspective
it thereby sets itself up in conflict
with other people's hearts and other
laws of the hearts the all hearts that
we're aiming at it also you know goes
back and forth it oscillates between
these two perspectives of the particular
and the universal and that's really
what's being worked out here so he says
it does not know that this realization
as what affirmative Lee is is in truth
rather the implicit Universal in which
individuality of consciousness which
entrust itself to it in order to be this
particular immediate individuality
really parishes so as it externalizes
itself as it Orient's itself in relation
to a world that has its own already
established order but which is felt to
be an order not acceptable to the law of
the heart an order that is crushing the
rest of humanity the individual in
effect you know submerges him or herself
through their action into this they
create a new order and they lose
themselves in the process and we saw
this dialectic play itself out in the
last several paragraphs as well but
Hagel is saying well that's what it sees
happening but that's not really
everything that's going on so what does
he say after that he says instead of
acquiring a being of its own if
therefore attains to being the
alienation of itself this is this is how
it feels about things and so you know
this sets up a kind of we might call it
a hero martyr complex right not martyr
in the sense of witness the original
meaning of you know the term our puter
right but martyr in the sense of being
the one who is is suffering or tortured
or injured or whatever for the sake of
some some greater value right so the
person motivated by the law of the heart
gets too in a way have their
cake and eat it too but in an ideal
sense they get to be the hero of the
story and you know that they're the hero
because they are so giving of themselves
and so following the law of the heart
that they don't even get to really enjoy
what it was said they were attempting to
enjoy we saw that enjoyment and pleasure
played a role in this as well instead it
encounters alienation that's how it
could that's how it portrays this to
itself that's how it thinks about what
is happening to it in relation to its
action in the world and remember this is
this entire section is the actualization
of self-consciousness through its own
activity it's trying to find itself it's
trying to find its happiness in the
world that's what's fundamentally
motivating this law of the heart it's
just different than you know seeking
individual pleasure so Hegel goes on and
he says that in which it does not
recognize itself is no longer a dead
necessity dead necessity could be
understood in terms of the the necessity
you know in pleasure and necessity but
it can also be understood in terms of
the universality or the ordering you
know like we've got here this divine and
human ordinance that was viewed as
oppressive just a few paragraphs ago
that's viewed as lifeless that's viewed
as absurd that's viewed as nonsensical a
little bit later it's going to be viewed
as you know oppressive tyrannical you
know superstitious however you want to
describe it however the consciousness
wants to describe it and he says it
doesn't that in which it does not
recognize itself is no longer a dead
necessity but a necessity animated by
the universal individuality so this is
as far as the viewpoint of immediacy can
go what's really going on however behind
the scenes or rather not even behind the
scenes in plain sight if the person
simply wasn't blinded by taking the
the viewpoint of the law of their heart
having their their you know viewpoint
you might say colored all one color
through the emotional tincture of the
glasses they're putting in whether
they're rose-colored or you know the
purple ones of melancholy or the black
ones of everything being terrible right
so if we go on what's over here well
this dynamic world that we live in a
world not only of physical events but a
social world the world of what Hagel was
calling earlier ethical substance or I
remember not everybody has this law of
the heart that they're you know entitled
enough or privileged enough to follow
out and try to change the whole of
society in order to make it conform to
that there's a lot of people just got to
work right and live and they don't see
it the same way and if you spend some
time with them instead of you know
engaging in whatever you know crusade to
change things you're about maybe you
actually see something more positive to
the life that they're they're living
they're not simply being crushed you
know in in the office in the factory in
in the cafeteria wherever you want to go
right so he says it took this divine and
human ordinance which it found as an
accepted Authority to be a debt
authority in which not only its own self
but also those subjects of that
ordinance would have no consciousness of
themselves this is again how the
individual seeing things in this
viewpoint of immediacy is is regarding
things and it's true in a certain sense
for that individual in the sense that
that is how they see it but it's not a
true viewpoint on the totality that they
are part of and that there now monkeying
around with and trying to change so
let's go back and look very carefully at
that again he says it took this divine
and human ordinance so we're not just
talking about
human beings in having a few you know ad
hoc processes in place and if the word
divine is turning you off at this point
because you think that's you know to
redolent of theology or something well I
mean keep in mind the fact that every
society has something it considers
transcendent even societies organized
around some sort of you know atheistic
point of view have something that they
wind up saying this is this is you know
the big thing and that can substitute
for the divine in this case right so
divided in human ordinance ordinal
structuring you know an order as we've
said many times that is what the person
is is looking at and what do they see
there it says it found it as an accepted
Authority well it is an accepted
Authority because when you're born into
a society that Society exists before you
and it had mores that antedate you and
you know this is even not only going
we're about being born worried about
becoming a self conscious individual by
the time that you're on the scene trying
to change things according to the
sentiment that's coming out of the law
of your heart your own self certainty
trying to turn that into truth out there
in the world there already is truth out
there in the world and it was there
before you came on the scene so if you
want to be successful you're probably
going to have to adapt what you're
striving for what you're yearning for to
that that reality to through what's
already out there but the law of the
heart doesn't want to do that instead
the law of the heart sees what's here as
dead authority as the pressure of
something that doesn't adapt something
that is irrational that that happened
right sort of like going back to the
phrenology section the skull is just a
dead thing right the brain inside is
spirit animating if that's something
living that's something vital and so
that is is how the person motivated by
the law of the heart is fundamentally
getting things wrong they see this
divide in human ordinance as merely
something dead something sterile
something static something standing in
the way and so he says in which it found
not only its own self and how does it
view it so himself to which it clings as
this particular independent heart
opposed to the universal that's how it
understands itself the rebel the you
know the Saviour the hero the you know
the person who is fighting back any of
those sort of tropes right he says but
also those subject to that ordinance
everybody else in the world right would
have no consciousness of themselves they
don't find themselves in that law they
find themselves being suppressed by it
they find themselves being categorized
by it they find themselves being turned
into something other than themselves and
unable to as we say take ownership or
buy into it when in reality if they
could look a little bit further they
would see people doing this all the time
and so when the person who is motivated
by the law the heart wants to come in
and change everything no wonder the
others who are other hearts are like hey
this doesn't really jive with my heart
I'm kind of okay with this system as it
is not just because I happen to get get
what I want out of it or I like security
but I actually like it here and so does
that guy and I like the fact that we
both like it here the law of the heart
is not able to take that in the law the
heart has to engage in a certain amount
of you might say self-deception although
it's not quite the same thing as a
deliberate process of self-deception so
he goes on and he says it finds that
this ordinance is really animated by the
consciousness of all that it is the law
of every heart and then he goes on he
says it learns from experience that the
reality is a vivified ordinance and it
learns this in fact precisely and
realizing the law of its own heart there
is a possibility of
ah gross there is a place where things
can tip over and the individual in doing
you know I'm trying to enact the law of
its own heart in the world can grasp
this larger vision and see that there's
there's a wider world going on an order
that actually has some Dinah Missa T to
it it has a dialectical process that's
not necessarily going to happen though
so it says he goes on and he says it
learns this in fact precisely and
realizing the law of its own heart for
this means nothing else then that the
individuality becomes an object to
itself in the form of universality now
notice the last phrase in which however
it does not recognize itself so what we
get is if the individual is able to
recognize something beyond a mere dead
necessity mere dead or during a living
world in which people are you know
connected together and living out
something like a culture and an ethros
together it's not finding its own self
in that yet and so that is where the
progress seems like it has to be made
thus what emerges from the experience of
the shape of self-consciousness as the
true contradicts with this consciousness
is for itself but what it is for itself
has itself the form of absolute
universality for it and it is the law of
the heart which is immediately one with
the consciousness of self at the same
time the established living order is
equally its own essential being and work
it produces nothing else but that that
order is in equally immediate unity with
self consciousness in this way self
consciousness is related to a two-fold
antithetic essence it is in its own self
a contradiction and is distraught it's
on inmost being the law of this
particular heart is alone that in which
self-consciousness recognizes itself but
the universally valid order has through
the realizing of that law equally become
for self consciousness its own essential
being and its own reality thus would
contradicts itself in its consciousness
has for it has for it in each case the
form of essence and of its own reality
you'll notice that preparatory to
talking about paragraph 375 I've really
marked the board up quite a bit and we
could even put more stuff in there but I
think that this schema as complex as it
is is quite enough to convey what's
happening here which is a very important
moment of realization that is going to
take us in the following paragraphs into
the second part of the title of this
this section the frenzy of self-conceit
so right now what we want to see is how
at this point in irrevocable
irreconcilable contradiction which has
this this effect of making the
self-consciousness distraught feel
rooted or zero roots it rather what
brings this about and the answer in a
nutshell is the conflict between to
universals where it seems like there
could only be one universal on the scene
so let's see how all of this develops
out of here in this rather short
paragraph this is what emerges from the
experience of this shape of
self-consciousness and we're talking
about egg salt right the gestalt is the
law of the heart and the frenzy of
self-conceit the law of the heart what
it starts with tries to enact it's
having an experience in doing so in
acting in the world didn't say
legislating or at you know engaging in
activism or building institutions or
writing in the newspaper or whatever
whatever it happens to do it making
videos right and so what emerges from
the experience of this is the true
contradicts with this consciousness is
for itself now that's a big problem when
you're trying to learn something when
you're trying to make sense of something
when you're trying to reconstitute
something and what you begin with
doesn't lead you to where you want to go
but instead seems to let you down and at
the same time it turns out that what you
feel is the disappointment turns out to
be the truth there's a moment or at
least some if you're if you're very
lucky a moment sometimes long periods of
an unpleasant reaction to that and
understandably so well this is what self
consciousness is now experiencing as it
has been trying to bring about the law
of the heart so there's a contradiction
between the truth and what this
consciousness is for itself now you
couldn't say well just abandon the for
itself right conform yourself to reality
that's going to turn out not to be an
available option why not well see what
Hagel says what it is for itself he says
has the form of absolute universality
for it so it's committed it is trying to
realize a kind of universal in the law
of the heart and like I've got here the
law of the heart and the consciousness
of self there's this going back and
forth they are really two sides of the
same coin would that meet in the
individual who is engaging in action I
don't know the arrow of action here but
that should be understood as taking
place so he's he says here that it's the
law of the heart which is immediately
one with the consciousness of self
alright the law of the heart is
something that one finds within oneself
so you might say well it's not exactly
the same thing as consciousness of self
but it is what Orient's the
consciousness of self I become conscious
of myself as that in which the law of
the heart is to be found and that which
can enact the law of the heart the agent
of the law of the heart you might say
now he says at the same time and here we
have the other side at the same time the
established living order the ordinal
term that we've been using over and over
again this established living order is
equally its own essential being and work
its eigen asst I ghen is interesting
here why because that is what the
individual has been saying over and over
again you know my specific my particular
you know eigen is mine right well the
world order has that going for it as
well because it is a reality and it's
not just a dumb deaf blind you know
stupid process that mechanistically goes
on a kind of determinism no there's the
mean you can't say that it has some sort
of you know vast consciousness of itself
real arge although eventually we're
going to get to something like that in
the end of the work but you can say that
there's many consciousnesses whose
activities have to harmonize with each
other that are guided by something or
some things that they feel to be larger
than themselves that encompass them like
the laws the mores the zipa the customs
right and so you can talk about it's
essential being its vaise in its essence
right and it's its work and here we're
not talking about work as our bites
labor the activity of work we're talking
about what's actually produced this goes
all the way back to the discussion in
the introductory material for this
section where he was talking about
something like an economy and how how it
functions so we have this established
living order that is replicating itself
it produces he says nothing else but
that its own essential being in work
that order is in equally immediate unity
with self consciousness so self
consciousness is here and it's also here
and this is a universal and this is a
universal and yet they can't be
harmonized with each other at least not
at this point in park is the law of the
heart wants to change all of this right
it wants to critique it it wants to make
its mark there and it wants to attain
its its pleasure not not a selfish you
know
hedonistic pleasure but the pleasure in
in satisfying this desire to to fulfill
and to liberate and to you know
ameliorate the condition of humanity
that lives under that order so he goes
on and he says in this way what happens
self consciousness is reduced to a
two-fold duplicated result right
antithetic essence it's anthro petticoat
and gagan Gazette's and visa now notice
the the language that Hagel is using
here it's antithetical it's and gagan
because they're opposed to each other
right and then he'll go on and talk
about zelt Vitas bracket that is
contradictory things as well he'll say
it is in its own self a contradiction so
we go from opposition to contradiction
and what do we find them there is an
effective you might say I wouldn't even
say reaction i would say embodiment the
the person who has a contradiction like
this who can't escape from it feels
ripped apart and yet not able to be
apart in their own being this is this is
a feeling that all of us have had at one
time or another it's worse than complete
loss right because if something's
totally lost you don't you don't feel
the loss of it it's at its absence that
is is galling and sometimes it's the
presence of too much that can't be
harmonized together that is particularly
distressful and so the
self-consciousness is he says distraught
distraught not just in a superficial way
but in its inmost being so he goes on
and he says the law of this particular
heart is alone that in which
self-consciousness recognizes itself but
the universally valid order has through
the realizing of that law equally become
foresaw
consciousness its own essential being
self consciousness is distributed you
might say over these two in acting out
the law of the heart one encounters the
world order and can't entirely escape
from it unless one just deludes oneself
entirely but that's not going to be
helpful either so he says the thus what
contradicts itself in its consciousness
has for it in each case the form of
essence and of its own reality both of
these are real the law of the heart is
real how consciousness is for itself is
real the world order is also real they
contradict each other and there's no way
to overcome that contradiction at this
point
you